megan king and cuff biden owens split
just two months after getting married
the former real housewives of orange
county star confirms the news on her
instagram stories writing on monday
quote i am rattled this situation is
profoundly devastating this is obviously
not what i imagined when i made my vows
and i'm shocked and saddened by the way
things turned out i am moving forward
with my children as we privately process
our pain and begin to let go of
shattered dreams megan concludes her
post by asking for grace and gentle
kindness as i navigate this labyrinth of
grief with my family the former reality
star and president joe biden's nephew
tied the knot in front of the
commander-in-chief and first lady dr
jill biden at cuff's childhood home in
kenneth square pennsylvania on october
11th the ceremony came just weeks after
the couple made their relationship
instagram official in september shortly
after their nuptials megan opened up to
brides about her whirlwind romance with
cuff explaining it all started after
they connected on a dating app spent
hours on the phone and cuff immediately
booked a flight to meet her another
candid confession from megan on
instagram she shares she's struggling
with anxiety and depression
[Music]
here's a video she shared on sunday
explaining how anxiety and depression
affect her and what she does to combat
them and live her healthiest
[Music]
life take me under the waters
meghan got some support in the comments
from her pal janet kramer and fellow
real housewives of orange county alum
bronwyn wyndham burke the 37 year old
reality star also got some love from
fans replying to one comment that she's
a big believer in therapy
honey where's your wedding ring
it is in somewhere in one of the drawers
did you lose it losing no i think i you
know what i thought about it today and i
forgot to look for it that was megan and
her first husband former baseball pro
jim edmonds on real housewives of orange
county back in 2017. they were married
from 2014 to may 2021 when their divorce
was finalized the pair shares three
children aspen heart and haze e.t spoke
with megan in january 2020 and shared
how things were going amid their split
where do things stand with you and jim
right now what is the status how do you
define that relationship
um it's
i think it could be better
it makes me sad that after
five years of um of a loving marriage of
with our ups and downs that we could be
in a place that makes me sad but um
[Music]
i'm hopeful for for um
for i don't know better communication in
the future
yeah